notre invité est député à l'ère du nord
sébastien huygue
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france alors le profil du tueur
présumé se profile après cette
conférence de presse du procureur
écoutez je dois d'abord avoir une pensée
pour la malheureuse victime pour sa
famille pour ses collègues
et puis avoir aussi une pensée pour
l'ensemble des forces de l'ordre
policiers gendarmes qui assurent la
sécurité des français au risque au péril
on l'a vu il ya deux jours au péril de
leur vie
apparemment ce monsieur est passé entre
les mailles du filet puisque le
procureur de la république bien il y à
quelques minutes de le dire que sur les
réseaux sociaux
il avait finalement démontré qu'il était
en voie de radicalisation et personne ne
s'en était aperçu il faudra que l'état
mettre en place un système de filtres
beaucoup plus importants pour est bien
repéré ces gens qui se radicalise un peu
seuls chez eux apparemment on n'a pas
trouvé de lien particulier mais il y
avait quand même un certain nombre d'
indices qui malheureusement sont passés
sous les radars des j'observe que l'état
est capable de filtrer l'ensemble des
réseaux sociaux pour aller chercher les
fraudeurs fiscaux
vous savez il ya quelques mois et bien
mercier a mis en place ce système qui va
aller chercher des gens qui ont un
comment un train de vie important par
rapport aux revenus déclarés
et je ne comprends pas pourquoi on est
incapable aujourd'hui de mettre en place
le même système pour vérifier détecter
les gens qui sont en train de se
réaliser puisque le procureur de la
république l'a dit il ya donc quelques
instants eh bien depuis le mois
d'octobre il y avait des posts sur
facebook qui indiquait ce savoie 2 enfin
la voie qu'il avait prise vers la
radicalisation et partant du constat qu
on arrive à identifier quelqu'un qui se
radicalise seul sait mais qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ensuite et bien
ensuite il doit être sous la
surveillance
des services c'est ce qui est fait
aujourd'hui pour plusieurs milliers de
personnes et donc il faut absolument que
l'état sont capacité de détecter ce
genre ce genre de personnage puisque ça
a été dit a également par le procureur
aujourd'hui il n'était dans aucun
fichier de gens sous surveillance ou
repérés comme étant en voie de
radicalisation
alors comment on identifie quelqu'un qui
se radicalisant sans tomber dans la
chasse aux sorcières eh bien il ya un
certain nombre d'avis on parle de
faisceau d'indicés qui permettent de le
détecter
et ça peut être des fréquentations
notamment de mosquées radicaliser de
deux personnes déjà suivi pour
radicalisation par les services de
renseignement et puis c'est aussi et
bien son expression publique via les
réseaux sociaux et apparemment il
l'avait fait depuis le mois d'octobre
mais ça n'avait éveiller l'attention de
personne ce qui me semble être mêlé
l'enquète devra faire toute la lumière
dessus ce qui semblait être un
dysfonctionnement selon vous est-ce que
la france pouvait vraiment éviter ce
genre d'attentât la sécurité 100%
n'existe pas mais il faut mettre tous
les atouts de notre côté pour empêcher
ce genre d'acte barbare
il semble que tous les mois les services
de sécurité des joues des projets de cet
acabit
malheureusement là on est passé à côté
et donc il ya nécessité de renforcer les
mailles du filet de resserrer les
mailles du filet pour faire en sorte que
encore moins d'individus de ce type
puisse passer et passer à l'action et
comment concrètement commandes
sécurisent davantage en tout cas je
parle le commissariat de france voilà
c'est relève du ministre de l'intérieur
qui doit mettre en place des systèmes
qui permettent de sécuriser les
commissariats mais de sécuriser aussi
l'ensemble des forces de l'ordre qui
sont au service de nos concitoyens et
qui on le voit depuis de nombreux mois
sont les cibles privilégiées des
terroristes en puissance alors valérie
pécresse était tout à l'heure sur europe
1 il a plaidé pour que la directive
européenne à clairoix zee de retour des
clandestins dans leur pays d'origine
soit complètement revu parce qu'elle a
elle a dit qu'il ne fallait pas nier ce
lien entre immigration et terrorisme je
la cite cette directive européenne
comment on la revoit basse et surtout
mettre en place des systèmes qui
permettent de renvoyer chez eux des gens
qui n'ont rien à faire sur notre sol
parce qu'ils sont en situation
irrégulière ils n'ont pas respecté les
règles de notre pays pour y venir ils
n'ont rien à y faire malheureusement on
sait que de l'ordre de 90% des docus tf
vous savez ces ordonnances qui oblige
les gens à rentrer dans l'ordre dans
leur pays d'origine ne sont pas
appliquées et la france est en
défaillance
dans dans ce cadre alors il faut des
laissez passer consulaires donc les pays
acceptent de les reprendre mais l'aide
au développement devrait être
conditionnée pour ces pays sur le fait
de récupérer leurs ressortissants qui
n'ont rien à faire sur notre territoire
je pense que ça fait partie des des
défaillances est de 2,2 au plus haut
sommet de l'état
c'est un véritable échec de la part des
manuels bacon dans ce domaine celui du
domaine régalien et celui de
l'émigration clandestine
sébastien huyghe merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
député l ère du nord merci